et vous dites aux garçons vous comme
Gisèle oui
super
les filles qu'est-ce que tu penses
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les paroles vous les connaissez j'ai
imaginé sans complexe qu'un matin je
changeais de sexe que je vivais
l'étrange drame d'être une femme voilà
le problème c'est que vous n'avez pas
encore changé de sexe mais ça va bientôt
ça va bientôt arriver non ça va bientôt
en ce qui vous concerne pour Noël de
Noël
on l'a demandé au Père Noël
[Applaudissements]
qui est Victoria alors moi Victor
tu es bomba
ah oui d'accord bien Victoria c'est vous
donc 25 ans 1m70 63 kg 95 c'est belle
poitrine très très jolie poitrine
qui est Axel Axel bonsoir 23 ans 1m76 66
kg 85 comment tu sais j'ai le coup
d'oeil
85B
Gisèle 24 ans donc c'est vous évidemment
un mètre 68 57 kg combien 85C non 90B
c'est pareil c'est des j'ai fait un
stage
et tu donnes pas les autres mensurations
vous êtes de quel origine française
voilà et vous
et vous Brésil
la chaleur
brésilienne
cette voix
dans la tête un an
[Rires]
c'est pas le courage d'aller jusqu'au
bout exactement
et ta voix de garçon
[Rires]
alors vous à quel âge j'ai pris
conscience que vous étiez très jeune
quel âge
j'aimais bien et vous compreniez pas
pourquoi vous êtes un garçon
que j'adorais et que voilà j'ai voulu
lui ressembler et
vous c'était pendant l'adolescence les
premiers mois quand on comprend l'amour
[Applaudissements]
ça ne sera pas coupé au montage s'il te
plaît
[Applaudissements]
quels ont été les réactions
de vos parents compte très bien parce
que depuis l'âge de 5 ans justement il
me déguiser en fait enfin
quels ont été les réactions de vos
parents quand vous avez dit maman je
suis une fille quoi
parce que bon elle a mis au monde un
garçon et puis
elle m'a quand même
elle m'a quand même donné sa bénédiction
en fait
c'était un peu difficile au début mais
après c'était ma mère je ne m'appelle
Gisèle son problème la petite fille ma
belle-fille 06 07
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu à l'époque
où vous étiez garçon est-ce que vous
avez eu des expériences avec des filles
et alors comment ça se passe avec les
garçons aujourd'hui alors comme ça
[Rires]
pour vous parce que trouver un
soutien-gorge à sortir un slipogo ça
doit être ça doit être impossible non
les détails donc
c'est plus agréable de toucher les seins
de se gratter les couilles
[Applaudissements]
c'est des trucs qui me passionne
c'est qu'est-ce qui est plus agréable
tu préfères
non mais c'est vrai toi
le réveil
ça vous arrive encore que vous pourrez
la gueule avec des potes
[Musique]
est-ce que vous laissez encore par
exemple les chaussettes traînées dans le
salon quand même un mec non non
un truc ça je garde tout ça c'est du bon
allez
ce qui m'embête c'est le regard de Volga
je vous en veux parce que je viens
d'apprendre que vous laissez traîner vos
chaussettes dans le salon
artistique de l'émission Frédéric Arnoux
est-ce que je suis un garçon désordonné
bien alors
sérieusement est-ce que est-ce que
l'homme est-ce que l'homme qui est en
vous parce qu'il y a toujours une partie
dame en vous est-ce que l'homme qui est
en vous s'énerve quand vous mettez deux
heures à vous préparer ben oui forcément
il y a un moment où tu as envie de
sortir tu vois bon
c'est naturel
quand la femme se prépare pendant 2h et
là est-ce que la femme qui est en vous
parce que c'est une dimension femme
s'énerve quand par exemple vous regardez
du foot à la télé ça dépend si les
joueurs de foot sont beaux
rêves bonne réponse et est-ce que
l'homme qui est en vous adore les films
porno
est-ce que vous dites que l'homme qui
est en vous adore les films porno mais
est-ce que la femme qui est en vous
trouve que les films porno finalement si
jamais que de la viande quoi oui aussi
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu